this is also time a small town in the
southwest of Germany where businesses
have disappeared and its population is
aging
here have elected a mirror they hope can
revive their Town Rhian al-shabel did
not expect to win an absolute majority
of 55.4 percent in the first round
this election sent an historical signal
but even people who weren't born here
and have only been here for a few years
are given this opportunity when they
make a serious effort work hard and get
involved born in the Syrian town of
ashuwaida al-shabel arrived in Germany
in 2015 after fleeing the war he barely
survived the journey traveling by boat
from Turkey to Greece then Chancellor
Angela Merkel surprised many by
accepting hundreds of thousands of
Syrian refugees saying Germany can
handle it
my experience as a refugee won't help me
act as mayor that needs professionalism
which I also bring but it does give me
one thing I have learned and that is
taking responsibility as a 21 year old I
had to take huge responsibility
after his arrival he learned German
fluently and studied the country's
administrative system
he received German citizenship and
quickly started dreaming of becoming
mere he had a very strong campaign he
went from door to door engaged with lots
of people here so we got to know him
quite well and when I saw what he
achieved in the short eight years that
he has been here coming from Syria
learning German completing its education
I just thought there's great potential
for the future and he will help us to
move this Village forward
because he has experienced so much he'll
definitely have different insights about
people compared to someone who has been
here all their life
for the supermarket also time will soon
have a new supermarket and train
connection as soon as he is sworn in
al-shabel wants to add restaurants a
kindergarten and senior homes
the new mayor will start his job here at
the city hall in June since his election
has quickly turned into a success story
of Germany's Refugee policy and a small
town of ostelsheim is now being seen as
an example of open-mindedness for giving
an outsider its Trust
but some are skeptical he'll be warmly
welcomed by everyone
it will probably be difficult for him to
work with the city council because there
are some stubborn people there but many
and also San Jose they are ready to work
with the new mayor hoping their town
will soon be more lively stepfather Al
Jazeera ososheim